we have a Detroit Michigan man
stretching across the table from me
right there I I would just I I wouldn't
keep to Detroit Michigan man but I think
it would really get him upset but that's
accurate your own Bennett's act like you
you say it fast I'll just say that he's
it for me you know sometimes in this
business
Jerome is I know you're you're in the
television broadcasting business as well
sometimes you pronounce the comma by
pausing right like for instance way back
in the day when Pat Summerall used to do
a promotion for Murder She Wrote he
would say Murder She Wrote because
there's a comma in between murder and
she there is a comma between Detroit and
Michigan so you're a Detroit Michigan
man I'm good good to see you Detroit
Michigan and there's a there's a sign in
television for fluff you know there's a
fluff fluff yeah that's exactly all that
was it was just all a bunch of fluff
because yes you don't want to make it
seem as though you're trying to imply
that I am a Michigan man I know you're
not the state of Michigan I did you wind
up but no how did you wind up at Notre
Dame I knew it was the best place in the
world to have gone to school close to
making a very bad decision did you
almost go to Michigan I did I must go to
mission so who was it was a Gary Moeller
who's surprised don't forget you so so
stop I will tell you the story okay I'll
give you the full story all right I
never would ever consider doing what
because you gave me the fluff early we
will go yes JK so I am being recruited
out of high school the number one
recruit in the state of Michigan at the
time both Schembechler is still the head
coach okay so it's both
okay so we go Christmas
yes he decides he's going to retire on
Christmas Eve
I remember this yeah I covered it I was
exactly
okay so Christmas Eve he decides he's
gonna retire well he goes to see one
last recruit before he retires and that
is and that recruit is the number one
tailback in the country that year his
name was Ricky powers I remember from
Ohio so I am a kid in Detroit I'm the
number one fullback in the country he's
in the more tailback in the country when
Bo Schembechler goes to see him that the
night before he retires it really told
me the hierarchy of the recruiting
process who was more important clearly
this guy was the number one tailback in
the country Michigan is a tailback was
tell back you kind of course that that
kind of deal so I knew at that point
what the deal was then Gary Moeller
comes in then they they they really
wanted me to play linebacker because I
was a number two linebacker in the
country right and then one fullback but
the number two linebacker and they
wanted me to be the starting inside
linebacker at Michigan and I wanted to
play running back and so then they came
up with this plan that they're gonna
play me like Leroy hoard more of a
fullback tailback type but I knew all
along that Ricky Powers was coming to
Michigan and he's an m110 he's going to
get the wrong and ultimately that was
was really the basis of my decision in
terms of really looking at Notre Dame
very very seriously because their
offense was based around the full-back
position not to tell that position so it
became an offense that really fit me
perfectly because they when they went to
three wide receivers the full-back
stayed in the game the tailback left the
game so there was a lot of things that
they did with the fullback
that nobody else did and so that really
once that happened then it pushed me
at towards notre-dame I'm looking at the
school so what you're saying is that in
terms of pissing you off about not
believing in who you believed yourself
to be this the Rams were not the first
to do that no I knew the reality of it I
was a fullback he was a tailback and
their tailback university I got it oh so
I wasn't pissed I wasn't pissed at
Michigan because I knew they wanted me
to play linebacker they didn't wanted me
to play running back that's why it was
such a big thing for them to go after
this guy so that told me okay they don't
want me to play running back they want
me right played I'm back and I knew that
but it was one of those things where my
heart was set on playing fullback
because my dad was 510 I knew I wasn't
gonna be a six to Greg Lance at
linebacker so it really I know it's
gonna be under sized to try to get to
the next level worked out I mean the
bottom line is like if you're gonna have
a fallback position if gonna have a
choice be I mean Notre Dame's are great
second short no but it was not me that's
a great that's a great that's a great
position
I mean Notre Dame's a great I'll just do
that
no the problem was that the leadership
was so poor in recognizing they were so
poor recognizing tell I knew that that
would be the worst place for me to go
because I would not be utilized to my
fullest capability because they don't
see greatness Plus using your education
is a lot better Oh tits on tenth I'm not
by the way sometimes it's amazing how
one story could be viewed at from two
different perspective
really only one perspective it's not - I
said great we have like three minutes
all of a sudden we went down the story
it's amazing and that's how I paid you
back it's funny I found the other day
cuz you know I moved into a new house a
few a couple years ago I found the other
day that Jersey that you is a big at the
big house it's October the lights middle
of the season it's not the first game
it's the middle of the season right I
know so we have time basically you know
yes we do all right so I got about a
minute left at your own bed it's 36 on
Twitter and Instagram it's great to have
you here but thank you man it's always
great to be home and and also four years
in four years about here yes
Hue's four years here ma'am yeah and
there's there's like a whole bunch of
Hall of Famers just strolling like one
thing that I want to make a point to
acknowledge is you know my classmate
Junior Seau obviously he's not here but
it's it's our job as classmates is to
bring him with us everywhere everywhere
we go so when I have a moment here at
the hall I try to just speak his name
just so good for you it's not he's not
forgotten I also told this class as well
they've got to do the same thing with
Pat Bowlen they've got to speak his name
let everybody remind people of his
greatness and that he's a part of this
hall so their tasks
is to make sure we don't we don't forget
the name when we're having such a great
time
well said Jamie you're good people man
thanks for coming on the show really
appreciate that there's your own Bettis
right here on the Rich Eisen show he
comes on he presents himself he tells a
great story about once upon a time back
in the day beau showed him the back of
his hand and he said you know what gonna
be the best decision I could've ever
made Jim Kelly our tool along with Matt
Patricia for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app